[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 19 février
merci de nous rejoindre dans fileco
votre émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout suite avec les titres de
cette
édition les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste se déroulent en ce
moment même à 50 ans nous verrons
l'impact de cet événement sportif sur
l'économie locale les soldes divers se
sont terminés hier nous sommes allés
voir des commerçant cantinois pour
connaître le bilan qu'ils font de ces 7
semaines de promotion le coworking les
bureaux partagés c'est une nouvelle
tendance qui séduit ceux qui travaillent
à domicile un nouvel espace a ouvert à
montiné le bretonux nous vous y
emmènerons enfin cette semaine notre
entretien nous allons aborder la loi
Macron son passage en force et l'épineux
sujet du travail dominical pour en disc
avec nous deux invités ce soir Bonsoir à
vous deux nous accueillons en plateau
Bertrand de Cré vous êtes le président
MDEF des ivelines et Dominique rier vous
êtes le secrétaire général de forces
ouvrièr desivlin également nous
reviendrons avec vous sur ces sujets
mais avant cela passons en revue
l'actualité de la
semaine les soldes d'hiver c'est fini
hier mercredi 17 février c'était le
dernier jour des soldes selon une
enquête média mari crossis réalisé au
mois de février auprès de commerçants
parisiens 75 % d'entre eux ont déclaré
que leur chiffre était inférieur à celui
des soldes d'hivers précédentes nous
sommes allés à l'espace Saint-Quentin
pour faire le bilan de ces soldes avec
les commerçants des images signées
William
l fin des sols de divers J-1 les stocks
ont bien diminué mais à l'espace
5quentin certains clients cherche encore
leur bonheur du côté des réductions on
fait la fin des sols le dernier jour on
espère faire des bonnes affaires et il y
en a encore il y a encore des choses
intéressantes là euh ouais mais bon
c'est c'est vraiment la fin la fin faut
trouver les tailles les couleurs dans ce
magasin de vêtements pour hommees on
commence déjà à mettre en rayon la
collection printemps été les articles
divers se sont bien vendus il a fallu
attendre la deuxième des marques pour
que les soldes commencent vraiment c'est
le bilan que fait sa responsable un
bilan un peu mitigé puisque le début des
soldes a été entaché par les incidents
de début janvier après bon rattrapage et
après ça s'est relativement bien passé
là on commence un bon au mois de février
donc j'espère que ça va perdurer les
attentats du 7 janvier ont lourdement
pesé sur cette période cruciale pour les
ventes selon une enquête médiamétrique
rossist 99 % des commerçants parisiens
interrogés ont observé une baisse de
fréquentation importante ces événements
concentrés sur Paris semblent avoir eu
moins d'impact sur les consommateurs
franciliens extramuros ça m'a pas freiné
mais j'entends mes amis maises de en
fait même de la famille qui veulent pas
y aller à Paris par exemple ben nous ici
peut-être on est en branlieu on se sent
plus en sécurité que Paris les
commerçants de l'espace Saint-Quentin
ont été moins touchés que leurs
confrères parisiens même si tous
s'accordent pour dire qu'il y a bien eu
une période de flottement la première
semaine pour certains les soles de
d'hivers 2015 ont même été meilleur que
celles de l'année précédente basket
survêtement dans ce magasin il ne reste
plus beaucoup de taille tout est là j'ai
un stock dans ma réserve déportée et
j'ai pu remonter avec les les solldes
j'ai pu tout remonter ici on a très très
bien vendu bien mieux que pendant la
période des fêtes et de Noël ça
fonctionnait même sans avoir de à faire
de promotions supplémentaires les
prochaines soldes d'été auront lieu du
24 juin au 4 août si les soldes
flottantes ont été supprimé les ventes
privées qui ont lieu toute l'année sont
toujours
autorisées c'est un concept qui se
développe de plus en plus les bureaux
partagés ou espace de coworking
rencontre un succès grandissant à
Montini le Bretonneux ne City a ouvert
sa 5e antenne les bureaux ont été
inaugurés la semaine der dernière sur
place yolen Torz et Patrick JAC de
dixmud pièce lumineuse design une
scandinave voici à quoi ressemble un
espace de coworking mercredi 11 février
ils étaient nombreux à venir découvrir
lors de l'inauguration cette 5è antenne
de Blue office à montinil le Bretonneux
un espace de travail de 2118 m² sur 6
étages c'est un concept nouveau et en
plus qui est juste au cœur du monde
économique de Saint-Quentin puisquon est
à quelques mètres de la gare donc je
pense que là quand vous êtes dans un
pôle multimodal quand vous êtes dans
l'endroit le plus fréquenté de 50 an d'
Éveline ça me paraît une très bonne
chose ce nouveau service est né en
octobre 2014 avant de commencer à se
déployer en Île-de-France 152 personnes
peuvent être accueillies dans ces locaux
nos prestations donc s'adressent aussi
bien aux auto-entrepreneurs qu'aux très
grandes sociétés aux auto-entrepreneurs
par le fait que effectivement qui n'ont
pas toujours envie peut-être de rester
chez eux isolés donc ici c'est un lieu
vraiment de sociabilisation on va
pouvoir rencontrer du monde échanger ce
qui est important effectivement dans le
cadre notamment de la création
d'entreprise on va aussi s'adresser au
PME et grand compte qui vont par exemple
vouloir accueillir des groupes de
projets sur plusieurs mois plusieurs
années qui n'ont pas forcément la place
de pouvoir les accueillir apporter une
alternative au télétravail c'est un des
objectifs de ces bureaux partagés en
France on estime qu'un salariés sur H
est concerné c'est le cas d'udrey elle
travaille à porte de clichis mais
pratique le télétravail un jour par
semaine à 5 eline son employeur lui a
permis de tester ses nouveaux bureaux on
est toujours tenté de faire autre chose
chez soi que de travailler ou alors on
peut très bien êre dérangé par par des
des gens qui sonnent à la porte ou
n'importe quoi ici on est plus
tranquille donc on arrive beaucoup mieux
à se concentrer et à travailler vraiment
comme il faut plutôt que d'être dérangé
chez soi et d'être tenté par mon et
PARVEAU mais je pense que voilà petit à
petit il faut ce genre de il faut ce
genre d'intermédiaire plutôt que de
proposer tout de suite le télétravail à
la mais maison c'est un très bon
intermédiaire pour pouvoir libérer un
peu les les collaborateurs et les
salariés différents forfaits sont
proposés pour profiter de cet espace de
coworking il faut compter au minimum 25
€ pour un accès à la
journée de bonnes nouvelles en
perspective pour le groupe automobile
Renault l'usine Renault de Flin sur
scène dans les es vient de relancer son
équipe de nuit la production va
s'accroître elle devrait passer de 490 à
750 voitures fabriquées tous les jours
le groupe a aussi profité la semaine
dernière pour annoncer qu'il allait
recrué en France 1000 personnes en CDI
mais aussi 1000 postes d'apprentissage
pour l'année 2015 nous sommes allés au
technocentre de Renault à gu en courour
pour recueillir la vie des salariés
regardez bah c'est c'est trop bien pour
nous quoi il y aura plus de monde il y
aura plus on va diminuer tout ce qui est
chômage tout ça ça montre que le coup
bien reprendre son son ambition et donc
il y a beaucoup de nouveau poste qui est
ouvert donc c'est c'est bonne nouvelle
pour Rena je pense j'entends aussi que
c'est aussi beaucoup de com puisque ça
ne va pas remplacer les milliers
d'emplois qui ont été perdus ces
dernières années bah c'est toujours bien
d'avoir plus de collègues forcément il
travailler sur des sujets super
intéressants il a toujours du travail à
faire de toute
façon que ce soit à 1000 ou même 3000 1
million on pe en embaucher tant qu'on
peut forcément il est maintenant temps
de retrouver nos invités c'est l'heure
de l'entretien de la
semaine et cette semaine nous parlons de
la loi Macron cette semaine cette cette
loi que certains qualifient de Fourtout
il est question d'automobile de travail
dominical des prudesommes il y a
énormément d'articles dessus pour en
parler nous sommes avec Bertrand Decré
donc vous êtes le président du meddf
d'ésivine je le rappelle et Dominique
Ruffier donc c'est le secrétaire général
de Force Ouvrière 78 alors tout d'abord
messieurs j'aimerais que nous regardions
un un petit un petit sujet nous avons
demandé au saintquantinois ce qu'il
pensaient justement du travail du
dimanche je vous demanderai une réaction
après regardez
ah je suis pour j'ai travaillé le
dimanche et je connais beaucoup de gens
qui travaillent le dimanche à condition
que ce soit payé comme des heures
supplémentaires de jours fériers pour
moi ça pose aucun problème les gens sont
libres de travailler et en plus la
majorité des gens le souhaitent et le
désirent si ça peut si ça peut rapporter
des S faire gagner un peu d'argent à
ceux qu'on ont besoin et si ça peut
ouvrir les commerce le dimanche sachant
que sachant que les weekend c'est moment
les gens sont dispos pour faire leur
cours je ça très bien ce n'a aucun aucun
caractère sacré pour moi donc ça ça
c'est une composante qui me gêne pas du
tout en revanche le généraliser non je
trouve ça très bien le travail le
dimanche à partir du moment où les gens
ont le choix et j'ai bien peur que
malheureusement ce soit rarement le cas
aujourd'hui ce que je connais c'est des
amis qui me disent de toute façon si je
travaille pas le dimanche je suis virée
donc je pense que c'est ça le problème
en fait c'est ça le travail de fond
c'est faire une vraie base de vrai
volontariat pour les gens qui veulent
travailler le dimanche alors Monsieur
tout d'abord Dominique Ruffier
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction par
rapport à ces réactions que vous venez
de voir je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de
personnes là par rapport à la réalité
qui était d'accord de travailler le
dimanche nous à force Ouvrière nous
sommes
contre d'autant que on connaît le
volontariat ça a été très bien par
contre ici
évoqué on sait comment le susciter le
volontariat on peut le susciter
par la pas du gain ce qu'on peut
comprendre bien que si on a des salaires
corrects normalement on n pas besoin de
travailler le dimanche et on peut le
susciter aussi en mettant le salarié
devant une obligation en lui disant si
tu ne travailles pas le dimanche tu n'es
pas embauché c'est une réaction à
Monsieur Decré parce que vous vous êtes
très concerné par ce sujet complètement
oui parce que moi je suis une entreprise
qui est ouverte le
dimanche donc je peux vraiment le dire
c'est du volontariat je même vous dire
c'est même quelquefois une incitation
une demande des salariés voyez je j'ai
un cas qui me vient tout de suite en
tête d'une mère de famille qui m'a
demandé qui m'a demandé expressément de
travailler le dimanche pour vous avez un
supermarché un commerce donc alors je
peux vous dire qu nos clients font leur
courses le dimanche ilst besoin et mes
salariés donc je reprend cette cette
employé qui a des enfants et qui préfère
avoir son mercredi après-midi ça lui
évite d'avoir à garder et et à faire
garder ses enfants le dimanche matin
elle travaille de 9h30 de de 9h à midi
son mari est là et ben ça lui évite un
fris de garde elle préfère 100 fois
travailler le dimanche matin que de
travailler le mercredi après-midi donc
généraliser moi ma position n'est pas
aussi tranché que c de Monsieur Ruffieux
c'est de dire que dans le travail quand
c'est utile que ça peut s'organiser sur
la base du volontariat moi je suis
favorable l'obligation limanche ça n'a
aucun sens pour moi ça n'a aucun sens je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui doit se faire de gré à gré et quand
c'est nécessaire et et dans le respect
évidemment du confort de chacun alors on
va pas faire vraiment de de trop de de
juridique ici mais il est dit dans le
texte que donc justement les principes
de compensation pour le travail
dominical ou de nuit ne sont pas encore
définis et des négociations auront lieu
dans chaque convention collective est-ce
que c'est un risque pour les salariés
justement euh bien sûr enfin nous on
considère ça comme un risque parce que
euh on va obliger les gens à travailler
le dimanche et on va discuter après ça
veut dire qu'on va ouvrir dans la loi
une possibilité sans aucune contrepartie
alors que jusqu'à présent il y a quand
même quelques garanties par le Code du
travail qui concerne qui concerne le
travail dominical et là on laisse ça aux
branches les branches sont capables
après d'ailleurs de laisser ça aux
entreprises et puis les entreprises à ce
moment-là c'est la loi du plus fort dans
l'entreprise le plus fort chacun le sait
donc le problème de la lo c'est que
c'est pas ass encadré c'est pas assez
précis il est pas du tout encadré et
puis même le travail du dimanche on est
dans une société où ça permettait au FA
famille de se retrouver là il y aura
plus de vie sociale à partir du moment
où dans une famille on peut avoir quatre
individus un qui travaille le dimanche
l'autre qui travailler le samedi
l'autre le lundi surtout dans le
commerce d'ailleurs les petits commerces
on va avoir des familles qui sont déjà
pas mal éclaté pas mal exposé qui seront
encore plus exposés à partir du moment
où n'y aura plus un jour que je veux
dire sacralisé bien que le mot ne
convienne pas forcément mais là on va on
va
complètement continuer la
déréglementation de la société qu'on est
en train mettre d'ailleurs des
réglementations du du du du travail
actuellement ce que la loi Macron c'est
aussi ça pour nous mais il y a quand
même un enfin voilà un pour une crise il
y a quand même un problème de
conjoncture si certaines personnes
souhaitent travailler le dimanche parce
que pour eux ça représente une manne
financière en plus alors moi je répond
ce que nous avions répondu d'ailleurs
Force ouvrière au magasin de
bricolage payer 5 % les salariés 5 10 %
de plus et ils ne se sentiront pas
obligés ou contraints de travailler le
dimanche sur il faut être alors plus
vigilant ce que vous attendez par
exemple de de cette loi qui devrait être
changé pour que ce soit amélioré ce
point alors sur le dimanche en global
parce que sur le dimanche et globalement
ensuite moi le le dimanche je je je
voudrais j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire d'ailleurs ici moi je voudrais que
le dimanche soit maintenu comme jour
clair net on ne travaille pas le
dimanche que après il y a certaines
professions les infirmières les les
transporteurs que après on fasse
travailler le dimanche contre
compensation financière et y compris des
gens qui ser volire d'ailleurs parce
qu'on en trouve à ce moment-là ça me
gêne beaucoup moins mais garder comme
principe de base on ne travaille pas le
dimanche après c'est discutable après au
cas par cas mais pas ouvrir le dimanche
où on sait que ça deviendra un jour
comme les autres et y compris cette dame
là qui pour l'instant a certainement des
compensations financières supérieures
quelles sont justement les compensations
financières alors aujourd'hui la
convention collective aujourd'hui c'est
30 % 30% sal sur la sur la journée mais
vous savez je pense qu'on se trompe de
débat euh parce que Monsieur monsieur
ruot comme vous je suis rufier pardon je
suis père et grand-père et et attaché
justement à la rencontre de minicale
mais la vie estant ce qu'elle est j'ai
une fille qui travaille à l'étranger une
autre dans le commerce dans l'hôtellerie
et une autre un fils dans le commerce
moralité les boulots ont fait que on a
un peu de mal à se voir et c'est pas le
travail dominical c'est que c'est qu'en
fait c'est la vie qui fait ça et je
pense qu'il est important pour les
salariés c'est surtout qu'ils aient un
respect des heures de travail
hebdomadaire qu'ils aient de jours de
repos hebdonadaire euh don alors notre
dit un jour et demi consécutif mais en
finte ils ont toujours de jours
consécutif la plupart du temps c'est ça
qui est fondamental maintenant et c'est
là où je vous avoue mais bon on pour en
discuter longtemps c'est pourquoi le
dimanche pourquoi le dimanche le
dimanche est sacralisé bon au nom de
quoi moi personnellement je je n'y vois
pas alors peut-être pour des régions
religieuses pour des catholiques veulent
aller à la messe qu' VI a le samedi soir
enfin bon la réplique est Laï que saès
franchement ex-moi je coupe la parole
pourquoi le dimanche al dans ce caslà
moi si on me dit maintenant partout on
prend un même jour commun qui soit du
lundi au samedi très franchement je m'en
fiche mais à condition qu'il soit commun
à tout le monde qu'on est bien à un
moment donné un socle où il y a un jour
qu'on va sacraliser quelle que soit la
raison quel que soit le dimanche quel
que soit le le jour de la semaine vous
voyez ce que je veux dire moi après tout
que soit le dimanche ou le samedi ou le
vendredi pour l'instant s'accordit sur
le
dimanche nos métiers que nos hommes soi
qu' soient militaire fonctionnaire de
police infirmier médecin euh travaill
dans le transport bon dans l'hôutellerie
dans le commerce il y a plein de monde
aujourd'hui qui qui qui sont en je
dirais en continu pas un pompier enfin
bon allez on va par tous les lycées mais
il y en a tellement donc est-ce que ça a
vraiment un sens aujourd'hui d'avoir un
jour commun je je sais pas mon monux
excuse-moi Monsieur je voudrais qu'on
aborde aussi le sujet des des prudemes
parce que justement la loi Macron permet
vise à faciliter les démarches à
améliorer le fonctionnement des prudomme
en réduisant les délais de traitement
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose qu'en
pense voilà en tant que représentant des
entreprises vous comment ça vous semble
cette cette réforme ben écoutez moi si
si on retient les choses phares qui sont
les chevinages en fait
c'est l'arrivée de magistrat
professionnel aujourd'hui on a une
justice qui
fonctionne certes tout n'est pas parfait
mais aujourd'hui il y a un vrai débat
dans notre de prudom il y a des
représent des salariés patronaux et et
qui qui qui rentent des jugements après
une discussion il y a il y a un débat et
ça pour moi c'est important et à
préserver justement parce que ce sont
des professionnels qui jugeent des cas
concrets je ne vois pas en quoi un
magistrat va améliorer les choses en
plus je peux dire je doute que on est
des effectifs suffisants parce que s'il
faut mettre des magistrats dans tous les
prudommes de France en on a C conseils
de
prudom des centaines de dégés je me
demande déjà qu'ils ont du mal avec avec
avec la jurisfice actuelle je vois pas
comment qui vont arriver à N mettre des
magistrats partout donc non seulement
fait on va pas raccourcir on va allonger
les tlés et puis moi je je sais pas ce
qu'en
diront débatteur ENF de moi mais mais
aujourd'hui notre justice je suis enfin
la patrale est assez attachée à cette à
ce débat contradictoire de représentant
des salariés et des représentants
patronaux Dominique refier vous les
prudom c'est pour vous c'est les alléger
c'est une bonne chose pas pas comme on
faut le faire c'est très clair on nous
dit maintenant qu'il y a des délais on
est même condamné d'ailleurs par
l'Europe sur nos délais sauf que les
délais je veux le dire très crument ils
sont générés par le gouvernement actuel
on avait des mandats qui duraient 5 ans
on a rajouté 2 ans de mandat et comme ça
suffisait pas on a encore rajouté 2 ans
ça veut dire qu'on a de moins en moins
actuellement dans nos conseil de prudom
yvelinois on a de moins en moins de
personnes qui peuvent venir parce
qu'elles sont parties parce qu'elles
sont en retraite parce que les listes
les listes d'attente qui étaient là se
sont
amenuisés ça a été organisé presque
siamment ce ce ce mauvais fonctionnement
ce dysfonctionnement et maintenant on
nous dit pour corriger pas du tout on
naurait pas rallongé de 2 ans le mandat
on aurait fait alors soit des élections
soit un vote moi je suis pour les
élections mais bon peu importe la
formule mais au moins on nurait pas fait
en sorte que ça ne fonctionne pas on
serait pas en train de se dire on est
condamné régulièrement par l'Europe
voilà déjà mais privilégier voilà le
dialogue plutôt que d'aller au tribunal
c'est quand même une bonne chose pour
les salariés vous qu'est-ce qui vous-
pré le dialogue il y avait déjà une
procédure quand on allait au prudomme on
allait en conciliation en conciliation
c'était déjà une PR phase de dialogue
qui existait qui était possible alors
après le salarié l'employeur se mettait
ou ne se mettait pas d'accord mais il y
avait déjà ce dialogue possible
qu'est-ce qu'on veut inventer de plus
maintenant on veut des médiateurs privés
qu'on mettra dans la procédure on veut
obliger à payer un avocat parce qu'il y
aura un juge en face c'est pas comme ça
qu'on conçoit nous la justice du travail
en tout cas donc finalement cette loi ne
fait ni ni l'unanimité au m finalement
au final vous vous retrouvez assez
d'accord sur cette et bien écoutez merci
messieur de d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et d'être interven ven sur
notre plateau c'était vraiment très
intéressant tout de suite passons au
chiffres de la semaine c'est du
sport 1,7 million d'euros c'est le
budget àoué pour ces championnats du du
monde sur piste à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline alors pour rappel le vélodrome
avait nécessité un investissement de
près de 77 millions d'euros si les Jeux
Olympiques 2024 se déroulent à Paris
sachez que le vélodrome pourrait
accueillir certaines éprees
euve sur ces mondiaux de cyclisme sur
piste avec le dossier de la semaine
c'est tout de
suite et oui affilé queussi on aime le
sport je vous le disais en titre sur
vous le savez en ce moment ce sont les
mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste à 50 ans
en yeline les exploits des sportifs
français les médailles d'or sont
attendus bien sûr mais ce n'est pas tout
le territoire de Saint-Quentin en Evine
a beaucoup misé sur cet événement les
impacts et les perspectives économiques
des Mondiaux 2015 c'est tout de suite
dans notre dossier de la semaine romain
rospiné pour le montage les Championnats
du monde de cyclisme sur piste c'est
l'événement sportif de l'année pour
Saint-Quentin en Yveline la première
compétition d'envergure mondiale qui a
lieu au Vélodrome est synonyme de
conséquences positives pour l'économie
locale premier défi attirer les
spectateurs le cyclisme sur piste n'est
pas une discipline des plus médiatisé
pourtant du mercredi 18 au dimanche 22
février le vélodrome affiche complet
5000 spectateurs sont attendus chaque
jour au total c'est près de 25000 places
qui ont été vendues entre 11 et 45 €. on
est un petit peu plus en valeur un peu
un tout petit peu plus de 300000 € de
billetterie de vendu pour les
championnats du monde les retombées sont
certaines pour le le territoire de 50 an
yeline tout simplement parce que pendant
les championnats nous avons un peu plus
de 300 athlètes autant d'encadrement qui
vont dormir dans tous les hôtels de 50
ans yeline on attend un petit peu plus
de 300 journalistes il y a aussi tout le
staff d'organisation donc ça fait
beaucoup de monde qui pendant un peu
plus d'une semaine pratiquement 15 jours
travaillent mange d'or ve à sa-quentins
en Yveline et donc consomme sur le
territoire depuis plusieurs mois le parc
hôtelier de Saint-Quentin en Yveline est
pris d'assaut la plupart des hôtels
affichent complet jusqu'à Versailles et
même dans les hautes scènes Cathy
couturier est directrice de l'hôtel
kiriad à Montini le Bretonneux depuis la
semaine dernière elle doit refuser des
clients de dernières minute qui
appellent de toute la France pour
assister à la compétition on a rempli
l'hôtel on a des réservations en fait
qui sont tombées déjà depuis quelques
mois donc nous ici on accueille surtout
toute une équipe de hollandais et puis
après partir de ce weekend on a surtout
des gens qui viennent pour assister en
fait au mondiaux mais on a la chance
aussi d'avoir une équipe donc ça nous
parmet un long séjour de 12 jours c'est
rempli à 100 % quasiment pendant 12
jours quoi donc c'est ça et
habituellement vous remplissez là dans
les vacces cou remplissez on aurait fait
du 70 75 %. pour Kathy c'est 76 chambres
qui sont occupées pendant de semaines et
quelques véhicules inhabituels dans les
couloirs autant de réservations en
février une auben pour les hôteliers du
territoire ils accueillent
habituellement une clientèle de tourisme
d'affaires absente pendant les vacances
scolaires si les hôteliers ont géré leur
réservation par eux-mêmees certaines
entreprises ont bénéficié d'un petit
coup de pouce nous avons privilégié
systématiquement quand c'était possible
les entreprises de 50 Ansel l'entreprise
de sécurité de Demba existe depuis 10
ans à 50 ans en Eveline sa candidature a
été retenue pour l'événement il emploie
60 personnes en CDI à l'année pour les
Mondiaux il a dû augmenter son effectif
en tout pour l'événement nous avons ont
dû recruter une cinquantaine de
personnes le recrutement a été beaucoup
basé sur bah sur la ville nouvelle on a
essayé vraiment de de privilégier les
les jeunes de de Saint-Quentin Montini
trapppe laarrière dembaa voudrait
prolonger ce partenariat privilégié avec
le vélodrome il souhaite nouer plus de
liens sur le territoire lui qui s'occupe
souvent de la sécurité de grandes salles
de concert sur Paris les championnats du
monde sur piste une bonne publicité pour
lui comme pour le territoire de nombreux
médias étrangers sont venus couvrir
l'événement ce rayonnement s'il n'est
pas quantifiable est un bénéfice
indéniable pour le tourisme ivlinois
comme nous l'explique Sylvie laouna ce
n'est qu'une première étape là ça donne
un focus sur le vélodrome le vélodrome
il fait partie euh des éléments qui euh
vont constituer des points forts pour la
candidature de Paris île-de-fance au j
en 2024 donc coup de projecteur dessus
euh pour nous c'est hyper favorable
autre conséquence plus étonnante
l'essort du cyclotourisme on commence à
avoir dans les ivelines euh
une espèce de notoriété sur le sur
l'aspect vélo en règle générale parce
que parinis par des zveline on a les
championnats du monde de de de cyclisme
sur piste enfin voilà on commence à
avoir une image vélo importante en plus
on est le deuxe département de France en
terme d'adhérent de cyclotourisme donc
on a cette image vélo qui est très
importante bah de part aussi la nature
de notre environnement qui est très
favorable et donc en plus maintenant on
a cet événement sportif qui vient se
rajouter à tout le reste donc on a
vraiment un point fort sur ce secteur
l'agglomération va-t-elle conserver son
titre de capital du vélo réponse à la
fin de la compétition le bilan
économique des championnats du monde sur
piste sera lui établi prochainement mais
déjà les organisateurs se disent
satisfaits ces mondiaux ont nécessité un
budget de près de 2 million d'euros qui
devrait être
amorti et pour rappel les mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste se déroule jusqu'au
dimanche 22 février au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin de Saint-Quentin en
iveline et sur TVfil 78 passons
maintenant à l'agenda de la
semaine cette semaine nous avons deux
rendez-vous à vous proposer mardi la
Maison de l'Entreprise vous propose un
atelier sur le thème des réseaux
d'entreprise au programme découverte du
club convergence civeline le rendez-vous
a lieu vendredi 20 février de 9h à 10h
donc à la maison d'entreprise il faut
s'inscrire sur le site internet ou par
téléphone 2è rendez-vous mardi 24
février c'est à la Cité des métiers pour
une réunion d'information bouger vers
l'emploi de 14h à 17h venez découvrir
cette plateforme qui peut vous
accompagner et trouver des solutions
adaptées à vos besoins de déplacement
c'est la fin de ce numéro de filecho
merci de nous avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
prochain numéro où nous allons parler du
Salon de l'Agriculture des agriculteurs
et des artisans ivlinois ne ratez pas ce
rendez-vous il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter une très bonne fin de
soirée au
revoir
[Musique]